us bombs are again falling on Iraq
fighter jets truck artillery belonging
to the is militant group just a short
distance from Erbil capital of the
autonomous Kurdish region in the North
for weeks Kurdish security forces have
been trying to stop the militant advance
it's thought they're being joined by
other Kurdish groups from Turkey Iran
and Syria but they haven't been able to
turn back the is onslaught airbill is a
base for US diplomats and security
advisors another reason for Washington's
intervention President Obama has been
unequivocal that he will do what is
necessary what is in our national
interest to confront ISIL and its threat
to the security of the region and to our
own security in the long run the White
House says strikes will continue but
ground troops won't be going back in in
the long term washington wants Iraqis to
maintain their own security that the
only durable way to stop ISIL is for
Iraq's leaders themselves to unite and
form a government that represents all of
the people as rapidly as possible within
their constitutional framework for now
though there are other concerns averting
a humanitarian disaster in northern Iraq
in the hostel mountains of Sinjar tens
of thousands of people from the Yazidi
minority are in desperate circumstances
they fled the is advanced with few
supplies the Iraqi military has released
pictures of its personnel distributing
emergency aid US military planes have
also dropped food and water other
governments have pledged to send aid
hundreds of Christians have sought
refuge in urban many are in the cities
cathedral the fear here is great at what
could happen should the is fighters take
the city